[Musique]
aussi insolite restèrent que je chantais
un homme à la fin d'un repas de noces
dans un bistrot du passage de dessin
aussi étrange cette trouée à cheval
entre la rue d'odessa la tour
montparnasse et qui en septembre
prochain sera livré à la pioche des
démolisseurs
on est toujours tenté de dire que ne
connaît pas les passages de paris ne
sait pas ce qu'est la douceur de vivre
mais c'est plutôt le duel entre ce qui a
été et ce qui devient qui affronte ici
irremplaçable notion d année écoulée
[Musique]
moi dans le temps quand on est venu là
il y avait le nez remet encore dans le
passage des petits oiseaux et tous lens
a bien changé depuis essayé vraiment que
depuis une dizaine d'années que ça
change énormément non non ça a été un
autre genre c'est un peu plus bruyant
par exemple un peu plus bruyant avec les
valent tout ça auparavant c'était plus
campagne puisque d'ailleurs vous savez
dans le temps c'était une ferme aussi
c'est pour ça qu'il y avait 1 à bâle qui
s'appelait le bal de la fpt le ban de la
ferme emma magri la quille en l'air
c'est l'ancienne grille de la ferme
vous allez regretter au bon c'est quand
on est 40 ans dans un cas et il faudrait
être un grave quand on s'y plaît je dis
mes clients tout ça les habitudes selon
connais tout le monde quand on est là
depuis si longtemps ça fait tout de même
quelque chose de s'en aller j'ai même
jamais mis en avant enfin c'est un petit
coin pittoresque la grosseur c'est bien
que ces vieux séparé ma faim c'est un
petit coin pittoresque qui va
disparaître de montparnasse c'est
dommage parce qu'alors bientôt on aura
pu se retrouver dans le ciment partout
et
mais
et encore quelques
l'heure pour artistes une dizaine dans
la région parisienne
peut-être pas 10 mhz
cinq ou six mois j'ai repris une affaire
qui permettent à mon oncle
28 24 ans que j'y suis lui était depuis
une vingtaine d'années avant c'était un
autre une autre famille
il faut nécessairement déménagé de paris
quitter le centre parce qu'on ne peut
pas trouver les locaux qui nous
conviennent enfin pour des métiers comme
le mien inter de paris pour espoir
possible
construit dans les immeubles neufs mais
absolument pas conforme à nos nécessités
et une cliente qui était rue rue du
moulin de beurre qui avait un atelier
qui convenait parfaitement à ses besoins
et qu'on a relogé d'office dans un seul
et grand mieux que ce qu'elle avait tout
à fait 9 mai au 20ème étage d'un une
tour qui convient absolument pas on peut
pas faire des sculptures au 20ème étage
[Musique]
et 50 ans
ici non pas ça je n'aime pas ça
12 ans
et vous allez allez si le passage
disparaît il faut chercher
pour trouver un local consorts
je prie
résoudra et la poésie du passage c'est
important la poésie oui pour les clients
surtout nous elle nous échappe le
président du passage a tellement habitué
à travailler que l existe certainement
mais ça se joue beaucoup pour attirer la
clientèle certains cas quand on dit un
client vient montparnasse c'est déjà une
référence pour le pour nous
avec la clientèle qui nous connaissent
l'impôt pour pompidou
[Musique]
à
et
ce passage était quand même un peu
transformé par ses différents théâtres
qui sont installés quand même
l'activité artistique assez seat ans est
assez belle je veux ma maman
mais je suis ta femme et moi ta maman
maintenant je me dis pas
aux millions nord
fait non ouais ouais les mamans aussi
elle fleurit elle tentant elle te voit
parmi les fleurs ne pleure pas tu l'as
ferait pleurer j'ai même paraître en ce
moment
oui ça marche plus en fait vous n'avez
pas du tout envie de partir à lons a
envie de partir mais on va être obligé
toute façon ce que le permis de
le démolir est afin de construire
alors je on espère tenir lac simone et
mon puis encore un maximum de spectacle
musical 6 et on n'était pas tout seul en
plus qu'il y avait bien le chic parisien
le kpd de gars
générer d'autres
cafés théâtres et les appuis sont pas
loin ici je sais moi je voulais vous
demander si lucernaire pouvait être le
lucernaire ailleurs que dans le passage
au dessin
on va essayer pour ferrari le garder le
même esprit non sont des structures
nouvelles
j'adore les vieux les enfants et les
animaux les clientèles gentille
[Musique]
27 ans que je suis là
la mentalité des gens répondent les
provinces vous savez moi je suis bien
que tous mes amis tous mes voisins mais
seulement si on peut plus dormir connu
plus de faim prenez c'est ça qu'il faut
que ce plan se reposer mais ton moi je
me lève de bonne heure le matin mettant
et bien je suis jamais couché à 20h30
00h01 eh bien vous au moment que je
commence à m'endormir c'est là que
j'entends crier au secours et les
machins comme ça alors ça va pourquoi il
est si spécial au passage où c'est
spécial apparaît en sur le spécial
depuis un moment c'est dans un coin café
qui est cambriolé trois fois ça veut
dire yeaggy m'apporter tout cassé l'os
honnête mais trois fois j'étais quand
même les
[Musique]
chiens il a mordu les fesses un cas vous
auriez vu sa
frappe est le meilleur il avait encore
plein d'ici de 10 po talent d'évincer
nord
voilà j'ai rigolé
pour qui les cafés mais mes enfants on
est une goutte d'or du augmente les
péages
[Musique]
je regretterai les consolidations maïs
que on a vécu j'étais tellement heureuse
maman
certainement y avoir un peu de ménage
puis aurait manqué peut-être ou
[Musique]
c'est un des 28 ans marié vaincu période
ainsi dans le passage de desa comme
ailleurs remporté ton le bonheur avec
soin et s'il n'est pas toujours vrai que
les pierres résiste au temps qui passe
du mois garde-t-elle dans l'esprit de
ceux qui les habitent r le privilège du
souvenir et les vertus de la mémoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]